okay we're going to be talking about
securing cloud applications and then
really in parentheses and their
credentials because the big idea here is
that we're moving stuff to the cloud but
really security has not kept up so we're
going to see what kind of techniques and
what kind of problems were encountering
and what kind of things we can do to
prevent it so about me as soon as I get
the next slide
I'm surgeon Gruber I work for cyber-ark
Rd for their next-gen identity stuff
pretty much the idea is I'm working on
the same stuff that I'm gonna be talking
about here nothing special I have a book
out diploma of a docker don't buy it
it's two years old that's two lifetimes
ago practically in our world so don't
waste your time or money but if you have
like a packet subscription feel free to
peruse docker certified associate also
two years ago not worth anything but you
can you can find me down there at the
links below alright so why should we
care like what why are we here
we're not here to really change the
world like every product out there is
trying to do like all we're changing the
world no no we're trying to make sure
that your data is safe that you don't
get a call at on Saturday at 2:00 a.m.
to make sure that your applications keep
running and they keep running safe both
for you and for your employer who pays
you to actually work but the primary
thing is around the whole
containerization world is that
organization are adopting this stuff
like it's some kind of illicit drug they
just want more of it like containers
give me more containers but really what
they're doing is they're putting VMs
into containers and pretending like oh
it's all fine like there's there's no
change in how they behave how they
construct things it's pretty much toss
everything into a container and
on a slide somewhere to some CEO oh yeah
we have containers that that's not the
way that you should think about this
that's not the way they should think
about this and you're the ones I'm
guessing most of your developers are how
you should present those ideas to your
higher-ups but the thing here is that
organization who adopt this workflow of
containers see I CD all of that fun
stuff that's popular nowadays you have
to be careful how you use it otherwise
you will get breached it's really not a
question of if but when because there's
maybe you know 10 20 30 developers
working on whatever you're working on
but there's hundreds thousands of
hackers that want to make money off of
your CPU processing power to nine
Bitcoin or from your data selling it on
dark net know what that all right so the
first thing I gotta cover is security
like the idea of security there are two
kind of camps in this and both have
valid concerns on one side you have
people that are developing software they
have deadlines they have features the
ship they need their stuff out they need
to be like in the clients hands and the
CRN managers on their case to get that
this done and security is getting in the
way like there's no question about it
the more security you have the more it's
going to get into your way of actually
doing stuff on the other hand if you
don't have enough security all your work
eventually is going to kick you in the
butt some hackers gonna get in there
they're gonna mind bitcoin they're gonna
spawn up some VMs in AWS pretty much
rack up hundreds of thousands of dollars
in terms of bills for your AWS or Google
Cloud so we have to balance these things
out but the main idea here is I don't
care what you have how you built it
there is no perfectly secure system you
can say that you've implemented all of
the Stig's for four
secure systems that the government tell
you you can have certificate
certificates custom CAS you can have all
of this kind of stuff but in reality
there's always some cat-and-mouse game
that will beat you
there's ro hammer they'll change memory
location of parallel processes Intel has
there any platform and it AMD has PSP I
think pretty much a different processor
running next to your real processor that
can change whatever the hell it wants
your phone has a basement processor that
does its own thing that can be rewritten
at any point long story short I don't
want to get into it you will never
really be secure you have to live with
that
you cannot say to somebody your stuff is
secure you can only given a reasonable
expectation that it will be secure for
this period of time with these attack
vectors out against this particular
number of hackers that are really trying
to get into whatever you have again I
really want to stress this point there
is really no fully secure system and the
only secure system is the one that's
turned off and buried somewhere in the
Nevada desert possibly bomb to all hell
like you can't have a really secure
system that's perfect
but what do you want versus what do you
need that's also another issue just like
the developers want some level of
capability to do their stuff unimpeded
the security people want all kinds of
stuff I've met plenty of security people
that are like oh just do all the things
that's a ridiculously bad approach not
to say that it's it's something that you
shouldn't consider but it all depends on
your business if you the way that to
consider it is really you're building a
bridge that's your security all you have
to make sure is nobody falls into the
river of hackers I guess I don't know
how to explain it but the idea is not to
build
the strongest bridge in the world that
will never never fail it's to build it
with the least amount of material to
last as long as it can against all of
the risks that are involved with that
particular structure so you need to
consider it what are my chances of
getting breached if your mom-and-pop
antique shop in the middle of Iowa you
know you probably don't have to worry
about security too much if you're the
DoD if you're SpaceX if
pretty much any of those companies that
have high-value stuff you have to be a
little more careful because more money
can be made on it think of the more
money that it can be made of as increase
in chances of you being a target on the
other side like I was talking about the
developers really not wanting to have
something in their way is you have to
also consider the friction of use how
tough it is actually to interact with
the security that you have because if
it's really really tough it's it's
useless you are hampering yourself
you're hamstringing yourself and if you
have more security than you're going to
never need you're wasting your time
somebody else's time companies time
everybody else in the process time and
that's where the overhead comes in the
overhead can be incredibly high for some
of the most mundane little things that
you have to do over and over again if it
increases security so just like a little
quick thing obviously can a completely
contrived example let's say you have 15
developers average wage is about 51
dollars an hour let's say you have this
portal that you have to login quite
often and you have to do it 10 times a
day you've added this two-factor
authentication that takes on average 3
minutes maybe that's a little too long
but let's say you have this and you have
to do it like every day you have to
think that this is going to cost your
organization or your group your team
maybe even just yourself
2,000 hours a wasted time that is
$100,000 a year that you can in theory
get a okay maybe a subpar security guy
or a girl whoever so consider that as
part of the spectrum of things that you
should look at it's not always just add
more security and everything will be
fine
like the balances are much more subtle
than that
again two-factor authentication is
awesome I'm not saying not to use
two-factor authentication I'm just
saying look at the cost if your company
gets breached is a hundred thousand a
good deal to pay over a couple of years
in general it is but it's something that
you should keep in mind but the bottom
line is that you have to have a security
setup that's warranted that is
appropriate to your system that is
seamless that adds multiple layers if
anybody tells you that you should only
have one layer if family gets through it
you should be fine you should really
consider if they're somebody you want to
trust I've seen a lot of like clusters
have external parameter Network defenses
and inside there's nothing it's all HTTP
it's all localhost everything is trusted
inside that is a really bad approach
think you need layers you also want it
to be automated and a follow principles
of least privilege you don't want
something to have more rights than it
needs to it's usually easy to do that
it's easy to make something just oh just
give it admin rights right that's that's
the wrong way to approach it it'll bite
you in the rear much later on you don't
want to do that generally all right so
where the containers come in into this
whole thing they add really they were
they were designed to ease deployment
it was the oh it works in dev kind of
situation but they add a lot of security
they
add this extra layer of indirection to
everything they're relatively low
friction they can be to some extent be
composable they're portable
scalable even now there's talk about
them being reproducible so if you build
it somewhere you can verify that it's
the same one that you expected but
they're not VMs VMs are much more secure
because they rely on hypervisors it's a
much lower abstract but they are much
more the containers are much more secure
than what we had before it's that extra
layer that a hacker would in theory have
to go through all right so what do you
get out of the box everybody knows about
C groups and namespaces if you don't
they pretty much limit and isolate
resources that the container that's
running has so it will limit the CPU
limit the RAM it will limit the network
connection it will isolate the
filesystem but one of the few things
that is not on here is that namespaces
for user IDs are generally still not
there yet
which means they're there for
convenience that that hasn't been
implemented yet very well what that
means is a root user user ID zero in a
container is a user ID zero in the host
so if you can escape out of the
container your root on the box same
thing if you're using a user ID of I
don't know 1001 which is the general I
guess most Linux machines first user is
1001 if your container runs at user 1001
you scape out of the kernel little
sandbox you are 1001 user on the host so
user namespaces is something to be
careful of here but generally things are
isolated and restricted which adds that
extra layer you have a single process
runner
you're not running multiple
processes in there there's exceptions
here and there sometimes you have to run
multiple processes in the container
you shouldn't generally unless it's kind
of like rolling your own crypto you
don't want to do it generally but it
makes sure that you don't have other
rogue processes just running around if
that main process dies container ends
and it's all protected by the host
kernel so you don't have to worry about
the OS of the container being out of
date as long as your host kernel is
up-to-date and then there's additional
things that you can add to at least in
some of the container platforms which is
the capacity drop Linux has these things
called
security capabilities that you can
selectively drop from the container
before it starts so you can say once
you're in this container I don't want it
to be able to make a note I don't want
it to be able to use the network I don't
want it to be able to make a file node
all kinds of stuff a lot of people don't
use this particular feature very well
but it's there if you want it you have
these additional perks on top of all of
the stuff that container platforms
already provide you which is the
discretionary access control what it
really is is just file system
permissions you got your you know read
write execute permissions on files and
directories but you also have mandatory
access controls a lot of people don't
worry about these but you can have
another layer on your docker demon or
whatever demon you're running that will
wrap all this up to make sure that your
container is not trying to escape out
and and accessing things in your hosts
Etsy there's a couple of these options
app armor seccomp selinux it really
depends on what your organization adopts
a parmer is most common easy to
configure seccomp is a little better
trickier selinux is
a nightmare of Licensing I would but
more safe but anyways I don't want to
necessarily get into it the fact is you
have these extra choices to wrap your
doctor demon into extra layers of
security and then of course you have
your truths like everything is running
in a change route the file system view
is not the same view that the host gets
so you get this another layer of
indirection copy-on-write layer so
container when it's restarted it loses
all of the previous stuff which I'm sure
you already know but it's an extra
security feature in a way and of course
image has hash verification that
ascertains that you are getting the
exact image that you want but it's it's
not quite all simple right if if I just
ended it here maybe you leave like with
an opinion that containers are really
secure but that's absolutely not the
case because it is too easy to shoot
yourself in the foot it's too easy to
add one little flag to your docker
command and literally undo every single
protection that you have just put on it
so well I I wanted to actually kind of
delete the slides which is talking about
specifically curing like most common
problems and how to avoid them I feel
like it would be the service to you if I
didn't go into specifics probably these
are going to age as fine as my
certification in the book but you know
keep that in mind I think these are the
current problems that that might you
might need to worry about and how to fix
them really first one mounting of the
docker socket into the container I'm
sure you've seen sometimes I think
pertain err does this a lot of
management of container platforms
require you to mount this so in a lot of
ways it's it's usable like it's not
usable it's valid in a lot of cases but
anytime you do that you're giving
the container permission to fiddle with
the docker demon in your host and the
doctor demon in your host can then mount
your hosts root directory that another
container can change so long story short
is if you do this you're letting that
container have root on your host it is
no longer a container if someone is
running rogue code in there generally I
don't want to mention docker because
things are now changing to OCI runtimes
docker as runtime is feels like it's
slowly fading away but it this is still
the biggest problem that I see around
it's like oh just run this with with the
socket and everything is fine or they
tell you - that ad - - privileged which
then also gives you a direct route
access to everything on your host don't
do it unless you're considering what it
all can do second keep up with your base
image updates whatever you're running
what I've seen around is people bundle
these things and then they forget about
them they forget that docker uses and
actually a lot of the other image
building uses this particular system and
caches these previous layers so the
first layer that you build out is
usually your programming language of
choice maybe some libraries and on top
your application right so all you're
doing always is changing the application
but these bottom layers do not change
you if there's a problem in those bottom
layers and you're like oh yeah I should
just rebuild the image right that should
work okay so what it really doesn't work
it's cached so you have to manually
break the cache at that layer to make it
rebuild re pull the stuff reinstall it
so this is very important there was a
lot of big vulnerabilities last year
where the bass up bass programming
language that you were using had issues
and I bet a lot of people were just oh
let's kick off
build and everything will be fine that
is definitely not the case
all right next thing is run the services
you run in your containers as a limited
user not as route with a huge caveat
here that sometimes you cannot escape it
like sometimes you're literally shifting
a whole VM like I was saying like these
are organizations sometimes they just
want containers your shipping database
this web server application card all in
one container so you might not be able
to get away with just you know running
is a limited user but try to do this and
that this mostly goes back to the whole
user ID zero in a container is user ID
zero in the host so by making sure that
you're using a limited user within the
container you won't necessarily have
routing of your box if somebody escapes
in fact most likely what will happen is
that user is not going to be mapped to
anything in the host at least not until
and things are gonna get better with
user namespaces as they get more and
more implemented but we're not there yet
another thing keep an eye on overly
broad volume mappings sometimes
sometimes I've seen some containers
wanting to access your dot config or
your AWS could like a lot of places
where you might have your stored AWS
credentials GCS GC GCP credentials so be
careful what you're mounting sometimes
they demand mounting at route all of
those things give pretty much root
permissions to the container that is not
what you want you want that isolation
and of course I've seen this a lot as
well repository TLS exceptions where you
know oh it's just an internal repository
we don't have to worry about it right
well just a man-in-the-middle thing can
just give you the wrong image I'm not
necessarily saying that this is common
but it's an attack vector that if I was
trying to get in somewhere
I would probably try to exploit and I
know a lot of people have this issue
another one this is another one of those
extras using static analysis tools for
your image it'll check out all the
layers figure out if there's any issues
if there's setup issues if there's
out-of-date libraries there's docker
bench Claire there's a myriad of these
and there's absolutely nothing wrong
with just literally running it through
all of them you can't lose anything by
running through all of it of course
there's a little bit of a set up but
can't hurt and then use of private image
repositories where possible or at least
caching docker repositories currently
when you pull your Alpine image or a
boon to image your your Debian stretch
image whatever the hell you're you're
you're pulling from from docker hub
those are based on tags right it's based
on the latest tag maybe even a version
tag but those tat can be rewritten I can
give you a working doc or stretch image
you will download it
security will verify that it's fine and
then I can push another tag to overwrite
that old one you will download then a
rogue or just a bad image so having your
own kind of private image repository is
ideal it's not easy to set up and again
you have to wait this according to your
your your security needs and then this
this one I would highly suggest a lot of
the operating systems already come with
this they have some kind of mandatory
access control around your docker so if
you download an ubuntu image you install
docker you'll have an app arm or profile
for it but these things can be tweaked
they can be narrowed down they can make
it even more
hardened and then what's out of the box
so feel free to use these they're
already on most of the computers most of
the OSS so don't hesitate alright now
that we got the specifics out of the way
that are going to be useless in a year
let's talk about a little bit more
generic right we wanted to take
knowledge that we can use everywhere so
we're going to be talking about modern
apps modern apps have been shifting
right they've been kind of slowly
progressing in a lot of very interesting
ways so we have to think about them
differently than we did before
so the modern apps rely less on in-house
code generally they rely less on things
that you have personally built or your
friends or your company you are using
more open-source libraries you're using
more code from somebody else you're
using helpers from some unknown person
library that you've never actually went
through and you don't even know anymore
what your app is composed of I've seen a
ruby gem that just does a string append
I've seen a node program that does like
indexing with a method that all of it is
a one-liner that somebody pulled in
because it was like oh it's easy I got
this NPM thing bad idea to do it that
way but the idea the general thing that
I want to kind of point out here is that
the exfiltration potential because
you're running more untrusted code that
you're running more code that nobody has
verified the exfiltration attack vector
is much higher and same thing with
malicious code that might get in there
just I want to say even less than a
month ago
restclient gem I think it might be rest
client John got attacked they pushed a
bad gem up there and that gem would ship
out all of your environment variables to
somewhere else can run code from
bitbucket possibly even run some extra
malicious code that's not even in there
so your applications even even though
they haven't really changed have pulled
in this stuff's like somebody's gonna
run gem update somebody's gonna run NPM
update pip update whatever you don't
know what your code of your application
is really doing and this is not gonna
change it's only gonna get worse it's
also one of those things that you really
have to learn to live with but the good
news is that all of these abstraction
layers even though they slow things down
they create a better system for avoiding
hackers from getting from one layer to
another and effectively rooting your
bare metal so this is the big take away
your applications cannot be trusted
don't trust them don't trust when your
developers well I don't know how many of
your developers were security people but
don't trust developers when they say
that your their application is secure if
you're a developer don't say that your
application is secure that's pretty much
it the reason being is that you have
written good code like you're the best
programmer in the world your you know
your your tore walls your like smacking
on the keyboard you know everything and
then you pulled in some library that
that's mining Bitcoin right you can't
escape it the next idea that kind of
this segues into so why are we still
giving our applications credentials like
it feels backwards to me that we have
these applications that are composed of
some random guys github repo that hasn't
been updated in ten years and then we
give them like the root database
password in our connector like the
security is gone right so what it boils
down to is this this little fight
between developers and security they
both have their valid points right you
have the developer that's just like
throws things into the container use any
library possible but you know like that
that Kanban board looks really clean
right and then the obscurity guys like
what did you just give me please please
don't but on the other hand security
guys are crazy because they want you to
literally spend most of your time
writing security stuff which will get
you and your company nowhere so there's
some kind of like perfect balance
between here that you have to choose
before you can both have a secure system
as well as develop features so this kind
of leads into credentials and secrets
right so you have these modern
applications that you can't really trust
and then you give them credentials to
pretty much every resource possible
these credentials you're like oh
whatever do we rotate them we you know
they're automated we don't have to worry
about it it's internal lovely blogging
but the fact is majority of data
breaches majority like a huge majority
are started with a privileged credential
abuse now sometimes you know you we're
talking about like a disgruntled
employee but not always these
credentials have a kind of like a
proliferation thing most people's
kind of cloud systems don't really
rotate passwords they don't change them
they stay stagnant so you don't even
know if they escape if somebody's gonna
use in maybe a little they'll use them
tomorrow next week next month maybe next
year and then it's going to be harder
for you to track them so where are we
now where are we now in terms of
securing containers and these
credentials that we pass into them right
because it seems like outside of the
whole configuration issue we have this
issue that we're still passing stuff to
these applications where we need to
secure them and what we've been doing is
you know like first we were doing
hard-coded credentials right that's fine
20 years ago and then we were using
environment variables and we're still
using environment variables because
that's what the twelve factor app thing
tells us to write but these because it's
so easily fetched and and looked at a
lot of the supply chain attacks are
targeting these exact things that
restclient gem that I talked about it
dumped the environment variables from
the process table shipped it off
somewhere else well guess who that
affects most it's not somebody you know
running a bare-metal thing it's not
somebody you know running a stuff on
their computer it's affecting most
containerized applications because
that's how generally it seems like we
pass things to these applications but
the problem is it's so easy for the
attacker to just insert malicious code
that just dumps out the environment
table ships it off to somewhere else so
that is something that I would like to
see gone I'm not saying that it's
necessarily awful but it's a very very
weak point
of every orchestration and cloud system
that I've seen around it seems like we
just do it quite a bit a little bit more
of a step forward would be using a
volume knob because then you know the
malicious code would have to figure out
which variables do I need to parse out
maybe even which file to ship it off
before so it like hats extra hurdle and
then you can also have secrets
encryption both in memory and on disk
that adds extra layers of difficulties
but it's it's tricky right because all
of these extra things you're adding but
in the end you you're adding these
layers for an app that you don't trust
so the idea here is that you you're
putting workarounds you're not really
fixing the issue and of course all of
this there's not a lot of audit trailing
right because these things are injected
into the container
beyond that you usually don't have any
auditing unless it's at the other end of
the thing so if an application connects
properly to your database but then
malicious code ships it off somewhere
and then uses that as a reverse proxy if
there's chances that you're not gonna
even notice alright so I might go
through a little bit quickly because I
covered a majority of the stuff that I
want and I'm getting good the signal
alright so what you should be using in
general for managing credentials you
should be using vaults you should be
using centralized locations where you
store your secrets credentials important
stuff because what they can do they can
segregate different sections of code
that you can have access to they can
encrypt them at rest encrypt them in
transit they are not part of the
configuration of your orchestration
they're not visible in plain plain view
it makes it really hard for somebody to
get them and then you can also some of
the vaults can rotate them so somebody
has your secret from you know two days
ago well it's no longer valid because it
changes every every day or every other
day
then there's authenticators which i
don't think there's too many products
for this but the idea is that you
validate on your native platform that
the application is who it is to get
those secrets so you tie the vault with
this authentication method to make sure
that the application actually has
permissions to pull it because you don't
want some Rock row container that looks
just like your original one pulling
these secrets but then you can also you
say that hey if this is running on this
host it has this particular namespace
maybe we should allow it to fetch some
secrets for a short time and then
there's also the whole last mile
credential enclave's the idea is you
take the credentials out of the app
themselves write apps do not need those
credentials they kind of do because you
know you need your database driver
you're connecting to various databases
and various api's but there's not that
many that most people use right you know
you have your Postgres you have your my
sequels you have your HTTP ssh right so
it's a very fairly limited set so I
haven't seen this too much before but
the what these would do is they would
take out the whole credential knowledge
from the app itself and because this is
a slight product pitchy thing but mostly
because there's nothing out there
you're absolutely free to like try to
make your own or something like it but
these are the problems that exist out
there
and we've been kind of working on a
problem of how do we do this
well we have this thing that we've kind
of been working on which is called
secret lists so instead of the app
pulling stuff directly from your
whatever your endpoint is in the
background you indirect it you proxy you
through secret less secret less injects
the credential directly into the
protocol type and then it gets stuff
from the database so it's like an init
container lives by your app so I'm not
saying that you should necessarily use
this particular tool for this purpose
but this is the way that you should be
thinking it is really hard to actually
like implement database protocols so I'm
not saying like it's easy
it makes things hard but it makes it
more secure and maybe for you the weight
of need versus want isn't there but if
you want things really secure you need
something similar to this you need to
take the authentication via out anyway
I'll skip this one it's open source it's
out there and I have no idea if I have
time for any questions but maybe one
question all right
that's that should be good enough that
one is a little bit tricky
like I don't necessarily have an answer
for you that would like satisfy what
you're looking for but in the end even
that serverless function is untrusted
you can't really consider it trusted so
depending on how you run it maybe you
could have something that lives close by
that does the same thing
yeah that's that's exactly the same
thing just just a little bit different
but yeah the idea is that you take away
the credentials out of the app you don't
want that and hopefully they'll be the
few way of the future all right that's
it thanks guys